so in these projects I like to speak to
three different type of experts the
first is former seite people or former
sales directors of direct competitors of
the company that you're actually
interested in if you talk to people who
work at competitors of that company they
will likely understand the market very
well especially the sea level people
often have an overall view on the whole
market and similar things are true for
the sales directors next would be former
procurement directors of companies that
would be custom customers of the company
that you would be interested in and the
reason is that these procurement
directors they will be the people that
will buy from the company that you're
looking into so these people will very
well understand what the buying criteria
are and how the offering of this
specific company differentiates itself
say from maybe offerings of some of the
competitors